hey what's up guys my name is eterno and
welcome back to my safe last class
series last time we talked about virtual
functions and today I'm going to be
talking about specific types of virtual
functions only called a pure virtual
function a pure virtual function in C++
is essentially the same as an abstract
method or an interface in other
languages such as Java or C sharp
basically a pure virtual function allows
us to define a function in a base class
that does not have an implementation and
then for subclasses to actually
implement that function if we take a
look at our example from the previous
video which is about virtual functions
you can see that we had a virtual
getname function inside the entity class
and then we had an override for that
function inside our player class by
having this get named function inside
our base class with an actual body means
that overriding it in a subclass such as
player is entirely optional if we didn't
override it then we could still call
play it off get name however it would of
course return the anti string however in
some cases it doesn't make sense for us
to provide this default implementation
we actually might want to force the
subclass to actually provide its own
definition for a certain function in
object-oriented programming is actually
quite common for us to create a class
that consists only of unimplemented
methods and then force a subclass to
actually implement them this is
something that often referred to as an
interface so in interstates being a
class that only consists of
unimplemented methods and acting as a
template of sorts and since this
interface class doesn't actually contain
method implementations it's not actually
possible for us to instantiate that
class let's see if we can make this get
main function inside and see a pure
virtual function to do that I'm just
going to get rid of the body and instead
of the body just write equal zero
keep in mind that it still has to be
defined as virtual but the equals zero
is essentially making it a pure virtual
function meaning that it has to be
implemented in a soft class if you want
to be able to instantiate that class so
by doing this a few things have actually
happened first of all if you look at
main you can see that we now no longer
have the ability to actually instantiate
that entity class we must give it some
kind of subclass that actually has that
function implemented so in this case
player for example and of course when to
provide some kind of string
as well you can see the player works
fine however that's only because we've
actually implemented that getname
function if I decide to comment out that
implementation you can see this we can't
instantiate player Evo so essentially
you can only instantiate the class if it
actually has all those pure virtual
functions implemented or a class was
further up in the hierarchy it's the for
example player war to be a soft class of
another class which did implement that
get name function that would also be
fine but the idea is that get name that
pure virtual function has to actually be
implemented in order for us to be able
to create an instance of this class all
right let's take a look at a better
example I'm going to undo everything
that we had done here
all right that was pretty good suppose
that we wanted to write a function that
would print the class name of every
class that we have here so what I'll do
is outside void print as my parameter
I'm going to want to take in some kind
of class type that will call obj for
example and then what I'm going to want
to do is actually print the class's name
so maybe we have something like obj dot
get class name so what I actually need
here is a type that guarantees that we
actually have a get class name function
we need a type that provides that get
class name function and that's exactly
what an interface is let's go ahead and
call this type principal and we'll set
it off so at the very top here I'll make
a new file called printable and the only
thing this is going to have I'm gonna
make a public virtual string function
the return of string here get class name
and it's going to be pure virtual so I'm
going to set it equal to zero then I'm
going to make entity implement that
interstate notice that player is already
an entity so we don't have to implement
printable however if it wasn't for
whatever reason we could just add a
comma and then implement an intersect
like so gives mind that I keep calling
as an interface but of course it is just
a class there is not even at the name
interface series because all it has is
that pure virtual function and that is
it other languages actually do have an
interface keyword instead of class but
these likewise does not interfaces are
just classes in a set of laws so now
everything has to have this get class
name function if it does not you can't
actually instantiate it let's go ahead
and add a
get clasp and function forenski now if
we were to do what we did here in sight
player I'll just write stds string and
get class name return entity then we
actually have a few issues first of all
our problem of not being able to
instantiate entity is solved of course
because we have provided that function
however you'll notice that we haven't
provided one for player so if I go down
to print let's make this a pointer and
actually call print with both player and
entity we'll get rid of print names that
we're not confused here here five of
course you can see that we get entity
printing twice because we haven't
actually provided a definition in player
however if we do so if I just try and
copy this get class name which of course
is an override let's not forget that if
I pop that down here and rename this to
player I can hit up five here to run my
code and you can see that I now get the
appropriate class name printing and all
of that is coming from that one print
function that takes in a printable
object it doesn't really care what class
it is we could create a completely
different class here such as a that is a
printable class meaning that it has to
have that function if it does not have
that get class name function then you
won't be able to instantiate an instance
of this class if we do something like
this I created a brand new class that
made of principle meaning that I have
implemented this function I can now call
print like this the course don't write
this code exactly because the memory
leaks but for testing its own if I do
something like this you can see that we
now get that a class printing here and
because it is a principal it is
guaranteed to have that gap class name
function that's how this whole thing
works because it knows that anything
that is printable how the guest Laughing
function for this to actually call if
you do not implement that function then
you will not be able to instantiate the
class so that's it that is what an
interface isn't it bus process what a
pure virtual function is in C++ very
very useful stuff the number one reason
is really used is the situations like
this where you want to be able to
guarantee that if I have a certain
function so that you can pass it to a
fairly generic method that we'll just
call that function or do whatever it
needs to do hope you guys enjoy this
video as always you can leave any
questions or comments you have in the
comment section below I try to reply
toes
comments as I can and I will see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]